اعلنت واشنطن حزمه مساعدات جديده لكيف عبر
ما يعرف بهيئه السحب الرئاسي تضمنت منظومه
الصواريخ باتريوت وتعادل رئيسا الامريكي
والاوكراني بتمكين كيف من الامتصاري في
الحرب وتعمى موسكو بعدم الاستعداد للسلام
بجانبها تعهدت موسكو باستهداف الاسلحه
المرسله لاوكرانيا وحذرت واشنطن وكيب من
تجاهلي مخاوفها ومن قرب تورط الامريكي
المباشر في الحرب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مغزى تعجيل اداره
بارسال منظومات باتريوت الى اوكرانيا في
هذا التوقيت وما دلاله اعتبار موسكو الامر
خطوه نحو تورط واشنطن المباشر في الصراع
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نفهم تاكيد بايدن
وزيننسكي ضروره انتصار اوكرانيا في الحرب
الراهنه وما صيغه دعوه السلامه التي يريد
لكريمنس معها منهما وما هي المقالات
المحتمله لنزع الحالي في اوكرانيا على ضوء
حرصي موسكو واشنطن وكييف على الحديث عن
السلام في خضم التصعيد العسكري وتهديد
بالمزيد منه في الفتره المقبله
[موسيقى]
اجواء احتفاء كبيره في واشنطن رئيس
الاوكراني
رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عن حزمه مساعدات
جديده لكيف بقيمه مليار و850 مليون دولار
تضمنت منظومه صواريخ باتريوت وقلبه خلال
لقاء ان الرئيس الروسي ليست لديه النيه
لوقف الحرب في المقابله
تقاتل من اجل تحقيق النصر على احد وصفه
وبعد لقائه بايدن القى خطابا امام جلسه
للكونجرس الامريكي بمجلسه طلب فيه تسريع
المساعدات الامريكيه لبلاده من اجل تحقيق
النصر على روسيا وقال زنسكي انه بحث عن
نظيره الامريكي مبادره اوكرانيه للسلام من
20 نقاط
اوكرانيا بالفعل مقترحات وناقشت مع الرئيس
صيغه للسلام تتضمن عشرا نقاط يجب تنفيذها
لضمان ام من المشترك لعقود قادمه بما فيها
عقله قمه الرئيس دعما مبادره يمكن لكل
منكم ايها السيدات والساده المساعده في
التنفيذ لضمان بقاء القياده الامريكيه
متماسكه
التي اعلن عنها لن تحتاج موافقه الكونغرس
اذ سيتم ارسالها عبر ما يعرف بهيئه السحب
الرئاسي وتسمح هذه الايه للبيت الابيض
لنقل المواد والخدمات الدفاعيه من
المخزونات بسرعه استجابه لحاله طارئه ومن
دون الحاجه لموافقه الكونغرس وقال مسؤول
في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان استعجاله
واشنطن ارسال المنظومه الدفاعيه مرده
زياده ضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا بهدف استنفاذ امداداتكيف من
الدفاعات الجويه وتحقيق الهيمنه على
الاجواء فوق البلاد
الرئيس الروسي فلوديمر فلاديميرا بوتن
تعهد من جانبه بتحقيق جميع اهداف بلاده في
اوكرانيا وقال ان تزويد الولايات المتحده
لاوكرانيا بمنظومه باتريوت سيطيل امد
الصراع واعتبر المنظومه اقل كفاءه من
المنظومه الروسيه اس 300 وفي مؤتمر صحفيا
عقده الليله في موسكو اضاف بوتين ان بلاده
لا تبحث عن حل سريعا للنزاعي في اوكرانيا
بل عن انهاء الحربه التي بدات عام 2014
بحسب تعبيره واكد ان موسكو ستسعى لانهاء
الصراع وانه كل ما كان ذلك اسرع كل ما كان
افضل
وكان المتحدث باسم الكرملين ديمتري بسكوف
قال ان الرئيسين الامريكي والاوكراني
يرفضان الاستماع للمخاوف الروسيه وشدد على
ان منظومه سافرت واي اسلحه اخرى مقدمه
لاوكرانيا ستكون هدفا مشروعا للقوات
الروسيه واعتبر الكريمن ان توسيع امدادات
السلاح الغربي لاوكرانيا يعرقل التوصل
لتسويه سياسيه سريعه وكان نائب رئيس مجلس
الاتحاد الروسي قد قال ان لدى بلاده كل
الحق في اعتباري هذا تسليم واشنطن اسلحه
كيف خطوه مهمه اخرى نحو تورط امريكا
المباشر في الصراع حسب قوله
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من موسكو الكسندر
جرونوف الاستاذ بجامعه موسكو للعلاقات
الدوليه ومن واشنطن السفير روبرت هانتر
السفير الامريكي السابق لداحل في شمال
الاطلسي الناتو مرحبا بكم
شديده الحرص على تسريع عمليه تسليم المزيد
من الاسلحه خاصه منظومه الى كيف حتى انها
لم تذهب بها الى الكونجرس للموافقه وانما
يعني سحبتها عبره ما يعرف بهيئه السحب
الرئاسي كيف تفسر استعجال واشنطن بمد كيف
بهذه المنظومه
تكرار
موافقته لان الرئيس يمتلكه صلاحيه وضعونا
نفهموا شيئا فان تزويد منظومه الباتل
اوكرانيا هي رمزيه اكثر من كونها جوهريه
فهي محاوله للبرهاني على
الوقت المتحده
جامده في زحمه لان مثل هذا النظام يحتاج
الى اشهر لكي يتدرب عليه الاوكرانيون
وحواله 100 شخص لاداره كل البطاريه منها
او نحو ذلك وهو نظام قديم عمره 40 عاما
وستتحتاج الى ربما 2000 من الصواريخ حتى
تحقق
مردودا لهذا السبب في العمليه رمزيه وهي
محاوله لك نظهر امام خلفائنا باننا»
اننا لن ننسى اوكرانيا
دفع بوتن باتجاه التفاوض نائب رئيس مجلس
الاتحاد الروسي كونستانتين
اعتبر مد واشنطن لكيف بالاسلحه خطوه مهمه
نحو تاكيد تورط امريكا المباشر في هذا
الصراع ما الذي عاناه همم
التورت امريكا في هذا الصراع وما الذي
يمكن مثلا ان يترتب على مثل هذا التصريح
بان امريكا متورطه بالصوره مباشره اكثر
واكثر
جميل من الولايات المتحده ان هاي التقديم
هذه الاسلحه الجديده
قبل كل شيء عليكم ان تحكموا بانفسكم في
اوكرانيا كان هناك
اعداد ضخمه من اجهزه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه
الصنع وهي فعاله اكثر بكثير من باثر
ولكنها دمرت تماما ان امريكا تقدم نظام
واحد هو اقل فعاليه من الاسلحه الروسيه
انها تدمر الصواريخ التي تقع على مسافه 60
متر
بين تكون المسيرات بمسافه اقل
سوف يقدم 10,000 من الصواريخ والاوكرانيا
يستخدموا حوالي 60,000 في اليوم اذا هذا
صواريخ ليومين فقط فلذلك هذا شيء رزمي
تماما كزاره
واشنطن هذه زياره رمزي حتى
يظهر للشعب الامريكي ان اموالهم تنفق
بهدف حقيقي
باي باي
التقى زنسكي ببايدن وبدا يتحدث عن تقديم
الهدايا مثل الميداليه همم وهي هديه من
مواطن اوكراني للشعب الامريكي وهنا تحدث
تريد جورد ان هذا مسرحيه
وبراي ان الشعب في الولايات المتحده
والبرلمان ايضا
يحدث
من اظهار الدعم همم الامريكي الجاد لاطراف
الاوكراني في همم هذا السياق الرئيس
الروسي قلل من اهميه منظومه باتريوت
ودخولها في همم هذه في هذا الصراع همم من
الناحيه العسكريه ولكنه تعاهد بانه سيؤخذ
بالحسبان هذا الامداد وسيطرت تصرف حسب ذلك
برايك همم ما الذي سيعنيه ذلك همم ضمن
حسابات المعركه على الارض وايضا ضمن
حسابات السياسه
هناك فقط
يتخذ القرارات التي لها اهميه وهو الرئيس
بوتن رئيس الاتحاد الروسي قال الولايات
المتحده بالتاكيد وحلفائها يردون الرؤيه
مفاوضات تمضي قدما تنهي هذا النساء واعتقد
ان الرئيس نصفي ايضا هو الاخر
ينقد يحبب ذلك اذا كان بامكاني
الاوكراني كدوله ان تحصل على اعتراف
سياداتها على اراضيها وقد يكون هناك حقه
اعطاء حق تقرير
الناطقين بالروسيه في بعض المناطق لكن في
النهايه
الاولاد الاولاد المتحده على طول الخط
عليها ان تظهر همه عاليه وعزم
واصرار لكن اذا ما
ان يتفاوض بجد بالتاكيد ولا شك ان ذلك
القوى الخارجيه اذا ما سميناها ذلك لم
تعترض ولكن
حتى نصل الى ذلك الحادثه تكون المعاناه
شديده من كل الاطراف وحتى رسلها يودونا
رؤيه مثل هذه المعانات وفي حديث المعاناه
همم سيد همم
الرئيس الروسي بلادي قال بان همم بان
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه التي يصير تصر
الجانب الروسي على تسميتها بالعمليه
العسكريه الخاصه بعد 300 يوم كانت الخيار
الوحيد امام روسيا واضاف قبل هذا التصريح
ايضا بيوم بان يعني همم هناك وضع ماساوي
للشعبين الروسي والاوكراني تسببت بها
الجهات همم الدوليه الاخرى نتيجه الدفع
بمثل هذا الاتجاه
هل ترى بان هناك
مثلا عمليه مراجعه او حاله ندم على الذهاب
الى مثل هذه العمليه العسكريه من خلال هذه
التصريحات للرئيس الروسي
اليوم
عن اي شيء هو يعلم ما يقوم به وهو واثق من
ان دولته لديها القدره ان تقوم بهذه
المهمه انتم تحدثت عن السلم وعن امكانيات
المفاوضات اريد ان اذاكر في كل خطاب بما
فيه خطاب اليوم الذي انتهى منذ قليل السيد
بوتن كان يقول ان روسيا مستعد لتحقيق جميع
اهداف
السالميه
وهذا ما سيحدث سوف نعود للمفاوضات ان
زياره زينب في الامس لم يتحدث
انه لا يعلم ما هو الحل العادل والسلم
العادي بالنسبه
انت بقى
قال
ان في اوكرانيا هناك
نزاعات دينيه وهنا كنيسه جديده اما
المنتمني الذين ينتمون للكنيسه القديمه هم
شياطين و عباد الشيطان
انهم ينتهي الضوء
انه يؤمن بالحريه
المناطق الاخرى انهم يعلنون الحرب الدينيه
على اراضيهم
ويقوم باهانه
القديسين والرجال الدين ويهددوهم
ويطردوهم وياخذون الكنيسه من
الرهاب يعتقدون ان هذا شيء طبيعي
في واشنطن الرئيس الذي يتصور على خلفيات
الناديين حتى بالريموت النازيه ابطال
اوكرانيين هذا شيء غريب وغير مرحب
بهنسكي في حديثهما البارحه همم
حريصها على اهميه تاكيد انتصار اوكرانيا
في هذا الحرب ما هو تصورهما لكلمه انتصار
اوكرانيا في حربها على روسيا
هو موضع في مواقف قصوه ودرجات قسوه من
المطالب وهذا ينطبق على
الرئيس
عن انتصار لكن لم يحدده بروتين تحدث عن
اهداف ايا كانت هذه الاهداف ولم يحددها
على الاطلاق انا اعتقد انه حتى
بدات في صباحي الغد فلن يقال هناك امور
جديده ربما هذا التصعيد الان من كل الطرفه
فقط
لكن علينا ان نظرك ان الحرب تتجه صوبه
حاله من المازقزق الذي
لا مخرج منه بالنسبه لكلا الطرفين انظروا
الى ما يحدث للاقتصاد الروسي
وموقف
[موسيقى]
الرئيس بوتن في اعين الكثير من الروس بغض
النظر عامه تقول وسائل الاعلام هناك وهمم
طبعا
عند حديثه عن الانتصار في هذه الحرب يتم
موضوعا في النقاط القسوه وعند الحديث عن
النقاط القسوه لابد حديث عن الارتدادات عن
هذه المناطق القصوى في حديث الهزيمه
والانتصار في الحرب ما هو تصورك
لامكانيه مثلا حديث الحديث عن همم تنازلات
خط التنازلات والمساحه ما بين المناطق
القصوى والمناطق الواقعيه
اجمل حكم على الامور كانت هناك
امكانيه على الاقل للتواصل الى حل المؤقت
وهي قضيه مطروحه منذ سنوات ساساميه
ساسميها باسمها الفني وهي اتفاقيه مسك
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
في الاراضي اللي عند مرحله ما قبل الحرب
قبل ان يغير صوت خريطه
يقبلونا ذلك ربما اذا تم اعطاء
تقرير المصير للناطقين باللغه الروسيه
اما كل هذا قد غير
ويسيرها باتجاه معين واذا ما حصل ذلك من
جانب روسيا ربما بيضا وزنسكي يصل الى نفس
الاستنتاج الحرب ستستمر طالما اراد تستمر
الرئيس بوتن تحدث عن
اهميه وتعهد بتحقيق اهداف جميع اهداف
بلاده ايضا في اوكرانيا في مقابل حديث
بيضا وقال بان مواصل التسليح واشنطن لكيف
لا تسهم في ايجاد تسويه سريعه للحرب التي
همم تشنها على اوكرانيا همم ما هو
الانتصار العسكري وتحقيق الاهداف الكامله
من وجهه النظر الروسيه
اقول ان روسيا لا تبحث عن
نجاحات عسكريه الحرب في اوكرانيا بدات من
قبل النظام في كيف ضد الشعب الاوكراني
ذاته في الشرق
في عام 2014 منذ ثماني سنوات في هذه
الفتره قتل الالاف من الاوكرانيون كلهم
حاملين للغه الروسيه الان هناك حتى ينهوا
هذه الحرب وكما يقول السيد بوت النزع
الاسلحه الاوكرانيه
في
اوكرانيا
اريد ان اتفق مع زميلي من اجل الولايات
المتحده ان هذه الحرب لا تؤتي بالمصالح
لاي احد لا لروسيا ولا لاوكرانيا الشعب
الامريكي الذي ينفق امواله على هذه الحرب
ولكن هناك شيء استثنائي واحد في اثناء
لقاء احد اللقاءات بين نيوزلنسكي وهل
كلينتون قالت
ان من الرائع ان الاكران هم من يحارب
الروس
ده السؤال هنا اريد ان اركز اكثر على
الاسئله التي طرحت اليوم هو حديث روسي كان
مهم اليوم ايضا لافت لي الكريم لين همم
تحدث عن ان ااه واشنطن وكيف لا تصغيان الى
طبيعه المخاوف
الروسيه لا يستمعان الى المخاوف الروسيه
ما هي هذه المخاوف الروسيه التي في حال
السمع طرفان اليها سياتي الذهاب الى تسويه
سيتم الذهاب لتسويه
روسيه
المد بالاسلحه في الحديثه اوائل الاستمرار
بدعم امل الشعب الاوكراني ان هم سوف
يحصلون على الاسلحه السحريه كما قالوا
الالمان في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الاسلحه السحريه التي سوف تغير المجاري
الحرب وعندها سوف يتوقف العذاب الاخراني
وهذا يزيد في احتمال تحويل الحرب الى نزاع
عريض جدا وواسع في اوروبا الامريكان لا
يخشوا هذا كما يشعرون بهذا الروس
الذين عاشوا حربين عالميتين ولم يحصلوا
على اي مصالح او اموال فقدوا الاموال هذا
ما يقلق همم روسيا بالمناسبه من الممكن ان
يظهر
بالصدفه نزاع
هواوي وهذا ما يخافه الامريكان والروس
ايضا
الاستاذ بجامعه موسكو للعلاقات الدوليه
وايضا من واشنطن سفير روبرت هانتر السفير
الامريكي السابق لدى حلف شمال الاطلسي
شكرا لكما الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]